there is a good news for the russian
capital moscow mayor says the city
prepared
300 fully equipped specialized
vaccination centers mr sabane also adds
that half of moscow is already immune to
coronavirus 20 000 of them through
vaccine all of them
feel all right but with all that you
have to understand that coronavirus
cases
and covet 19 related deaths remain on a
very high level
here in moscow and across russia and
pandemic restrictions remain in force in
so many places just to remind you
sputnikville
is currently undergoing phase three of
its clinical trials
early interim results just recently
showed that the drug is 95
effective 42 days after the first dose
developers expect to produce up to 2
million doses
till the end of this year meanwhile
other vaccines are also getting ready to
enter global markets some of them with
some difficulties
the uk sweden astrozenica will be
trialled again
amid mountain questions over dosage
issues
russia suggests combining it with
sputnik v vaccine
to boost efficacy current full dose
astrazeneca regimen resulted in 62
percent efficacy
if they go for a new clinical trial we
suggest
trying a regimen of combining the
astrazeneca shot with the sputnik v
human adenoviral vector shot to boost
efficacy
combining vaccines may prove important
for re-vaccinations
there was no immediate response from the
company behind astrazeneca russia is
still waiting for
their reaction other vaccines are also
there the us-based farm giants
pfizer and modernists say their drugs
were also over
95 effective well as russia says the
more vaccines the better
and i think we would rather all agree
with that
you